it's ground processing
thanks
uh let me start by saying that uh the
organizers
did a really good job putting this
workshop together it's my great pleasure
to be speaking here
and the the paper i'm going to present
this is a result of collaboration with
venkat guruswamy
so the
steeming model for graphs
has been mentioned multiple times in
this workshop but just to make sure that
everyone's on the same page
in this
in this in this model
uh a streaming algorithm has access to a
long uh stream of edges and can read
them one by one
and the usual goal in this kind of
research is to minimize the amount of
memory that algorithm needs to to
provide answer to some combinatorial
problem
and what is usually allowed in such a
case is above randomization the
algorithm can use
random cointosses
and we are also uh
we also won't complain with errors with
small probability
so let me also just say that in general
we're going to assume worst case or the
ring of edges as opposed to
around about the ring of edges so you
can think of this in the following way
so there is some adversary who knows
your algorithm
and this adversary can pick the order of
edges
based uh based on the algorithm
but
he or she doesn't know uh the random
coin tosses of the algorithm
so in particular in this in in this in
this talk i'm gonna pre i'm gonna focus
uh on the
multipass model so an algorithm is going
to be allowed to see the input a few
times
so every time the the the the ordering
of edges in the stream is going to be
the same
so you could make sure you could first
you could ask does it make sense to
consider this kind of model and the
answer is yes because if
if the data is on some large external
storage device
then sequential access
is is likely to maximize the throughput
so if you are uh so if you are able to
see the data once even if it takes you
say one day then if you don't need uh
the answer to your question very quickly
then perhaps you'll be fine with with
making a few passes like five passes for
instance
so
for graph streaming
what has
become a standard is to strive for
algorithms that use
the amount of space which is roughly the
number of vertices times some polylog
right so intuitively this is this enough
to store uh
some some a little a little bit of
information for every vertex
but it's not enough to store all the
edges if the graph is if the graph is
dense
it kind of makes sense to consider this
kind of model because for most problems
if you want to compute something for a
graph if you use less memory
than
the number of vertices
then it's very easy to show that there's
actually nothing you can do
so so the challenge is uh to uh uh so
enjoy the change has become to find
algorithms that use this much memory
and use
a few uh a small number of passes
right and and in this this work i'm
presenting today is
we're gonna rule out a possibility of
such uh
algorithms for uh for a few basic graph
problems
so what are so what are our problems
so p in general let me just mention is
gonna be a number of passes right so so
so the first problem we're gonna look at
is the most basic crime we're to look at
is we have an undirected graph and the
question is
are two
vertices specified in advance at
distance at most two times p plus one
so this is the first problem the second
problem is uh
is there a perfect matching in the graph
and the third problem is uh is there a
directed path from one pre-specified
vertex to another pre-specified vertex
all right so these are three problems
that uh we're gonna approve lower bounds
for
and uh
for all these problems we show that if
you use p passes then the amount of
memory that you have to use is at least
end to the one plus some con some
constant times one over p essentially
for for a constant for a constant uh
number of passes
okay so
it's always known about these problems
before
there was a paper by feigenbau at all
who showed that if if you are allowed
only one pass then solving any of these
problems requires n square uh
bits of memory right so essentially you
have to store the entire graph to be
able in the memory to be able to solve
this problem
it's also easy to show that if you are
allowed p passes then uh by using set
disjointness in a standard way that the
amount of memory you need is n over p
but the problem here is we want to solve
to show lower bounds which are
significantly
stronger that
the amount of memory we're gonna use is
n to the one plus some small constant
that depends on p
so the main challenge uh in this kind of
situation becomes to somehow embed a
hard
communication problem into the space of
edges not just into the space of
vertices so for instance in the case of
of this lower bound that uses set
disjointness
we embed
we embed
an instance of set disjointness into
essentially the space of vertices right
but we have to somehow the heart problem
has to be encoded using edges
and it has to has to be
a dense graph
so let me mention a related result which
is a computing shortest buffs
so uh feigenbaum and all showed that uh
if you want to compute a bfs3 up to some
constant
distance starting from some specific
specified vertex
then
if you use
if you use less than k passes and the
depth of a tree is more than k is at
least k
then the amount of memory that you're
gonna you have to use is is n to the one
plus one over k roughly
right so so so so so at least uh so at
least the equation describing the lower
bound is very similar in this case
but our problem is is is more difficult
when it comes to proving lower bounds
because it's easier for algorithms
so so in their in their case
they were able to show that if we are
interested in things which are at
distance k
if you use less than k minus 1
less than less than k
passes then this is going to require a
super linear amount of memory
in our case what you can do is you can
start simulating bfs from both vertices
that are interested in
and
after roughly k over two passes you can
check if if if the bfs trees that you
computed from from those two
from those two vertices whether they
intersect or not
and so because of that it's this problem
is is is easier for our griffins but
it's harder to prove lorman's
so so for starters let me let's look at
uh let's look at the lower bundle if i
get above it all
i'm going to give you a brief sketch of
how it works
uh so we're going to look at the perfect
matching problem
right so so we're going to have four
columns of vertices we're going to have
an arbitrary graph bipartite graph
between the uh between the two uh
two middle columns of vertices
and then we add uh almost the perfect
matching
of the of the middle columns of vertices
with the with the outer corners of each
vertices right so you can see that two
vertices are not connected
so now the question whether there is a
perfect matching in this graph becomes
essentially the question whether whether
these two vertices are connected or not
right
so what can happen now
is if the streaming algorithm is first
shown the the middle layer of of edges
and then it's shown the outer layers of
edges it doesn't know
uh that if it doesn't use enough memory
it won't know
which uh
which uh whether those two vertices that
are not connected
that don't have that are not much to the
outer layers whether they are connected
or not
right this is basically a lower bound
via the problem called uh indexing right
so so alice is gonna have
uh alice is gonna have an array of uh
an array of a binary array of length and
square roughly and bob
and bob's task is to identify based on
the message from alice whether this
specific uh
beat in the array is zero or one
right so so so just just to make sure
that everyone's on the same page if if
you want to show a lower bound for
streaming algorithms it suffices to show
that if you partition the stream into
two parts
that
the communication problem
could that if we had a good algorithm
the communication problem could be
solved using uh using the streaming
algorithm because alice could simulate
uh they'll
could start simulating the algorithm on
her part of the input and then it could
pass the state of the algorithm as a in
the message to bob and bob would just
continue simulating uh simulating this
algorithm
right so if the streaming graph can be
used to solve this problem
then uh it also implies a good
communication protocol
okay so
uh so it's easy to modify this instance
to show that for instance approximation
uh better than
five over three for the shortest path
problem
also requires uh n square space right we
just we just remove these edges in the
matching and out edges that tell us uh
which two vertices we want uh to connect
right it's essentially the same the same
instance
right so so like slightly on the more
philosophical level um
uh what's like the important part in
designing these kinds of lower bounds
for streaming algorithms is uh is to
decide how we order edges in the stream
and to some extent uh
what are graphs graphs are vertices
right and some relations between them
and solving most graph problems requires
some kind of exploration of of this of
the structure of the graph
and to prove uh lower bounds he wants to
create some kind of obstacle uh for for
exploration
right and and and what you've seen in
this in these two problems is to present
uh one way to do this is to present
edges layers of edges in the order which
is opposite to what uh
what would be suitable for this kind of
problem right like for instance for the
matching problem we've seen we've first
seen the
uh the algorithm would first see the
edges in the middle layer and then the
outer layers if it were shown
these two
parts of the input in the opposite order
the problem would be relatively easy
and it could easily solve it in
constant memory
okay so let me now present uh
what is
our heart instance
right so let's start with the perfect
matching we're gonna this time have
multiple columns of
uh of of uh
of edges
right and now i'm going to remove one of
the outer vertices on each of the sides
and i'm going to add
some some complicated sets of
connections in between
between those columns of uh of edges
that i already had
right so now the question
uh
is there a perfect matching becomes a
question becomes the question is there
an augmenting path between those two
vertices that are not much now right
right so an augmenting path is a path
that alternates between
uh edges in the matching and and edges
outside of the matching and by applying
such an augmenting path you you can you
can improve the matching and it's well
known that this is like the only way to
to check if if in this situation if you
are missing one edge from a perfect
matching whether there is a perfect
magic in the graph
okay so
another way to look at this problem by
slightly modifying the graph again is is
there a path
and the question you could ask is there
a path of a specific length in this tie
in this case nine between those two red
nodes right
so you can even simplify this instance
further
by by removing uh removing uh layers the
columns of of
of matchings right so so then you then
you end up with uh with a problem like
this
so as i said now it's important in what
uh order an algorithm is presenting
these edges in this instance right and
and again we're gonna do it in the worst
possible order for the algorithm we're
gonna start from the middle right so
first we're gonna present the edges from
the middle one two three and four five
six
right if we presented them in a
different order if you present them in
order say three to one and then five is
six five four
then uh it would be very easy for the
algorithm in
linear memory to find out whether
there is a there is a
directed path from one side to the other
so
so as i said before we're going to
assign each layer to one player
and
we'll we'll try to
prove a
communication lower bound for this kind
of problem where the players are
forced to speak in a very specific order
okay so now i'm going to
try to give you some sketch of the proof
of how we prove communication overbound
for this for this problem
so let me introduce for starters a very
a classic uh problem called pointer
chasing
so in this case we're gonna have p
functions
and from uh from a set of size n two to
the same set of size n
and the goal is to compute
uh
uh
basically compose all these functions
and and compute the result for some
fixed uh parameters say say one
right so it's basically if you if you
see these functions as uh
layers in a directed graph the question
is starting from a specific vertex on
the left where do we end up on the right
right so uh so so so let me first tell
you about the classic two-player version
of this problem
uh so uh so players are gonna so every
other so each play is gonna have every
other layer
every other function every other layer
in this graph that we've just seen and
if we just wanted to compute this
function the simplest way we would first
apply the first function then you apply
the second function the result of the
previous computation and so on
right and
so
so as you see i assigned f1 f3 and f5 to
bob and f2 f4 and f6 and so on to alice
right so like the most natural way for
the players to would be for for bob to
speak first because he could uh compute
the first of the application of the
first function and so on but if we force
alice to speak first
then it turns out that if the number of
of communication rounds that they are
allowed
is
is less than p
then the communication requires omega
and computation communication the
computation requires omega n
communication
right so so if bob were allowed to speak
first and if we had the same number of
rounds then
then the problem would be easy with
basically sending one word per
per round of computation
so so for this specific problem we will
be interested in a p player version of
this
of this problem
so the first player is going to be given
the last the last function the second
player is going to be given the second
to last function
and in each round the players will be
forced to speak in order player 1
through through player p
so
goku and mcgregor extended
the the result of nissan wilgerson and
they showed that
if you use less than p rounds of
computation
of communication then this is going to
require omega and communication overall
for a constant number of rounds
so let me look at the the lower bound of
fighting bound all for computing the
bfs3 how how their proof went
so
so what they did is they
they took the communication lower bank
for pointer chasing
right then they applied a direct sum
theorem of jain radhakrishnan sen
which uh basically says that if you want
to solve k instances of of a
communication problem in a cons in a
small number of rounds
then
then the total amount of communication
has to be k times the amount of
communication that is required for a
single instance of the problem
and using that they showed that
if you want to compute
a bfs3
then if you can do it in a small amount
of memory then you can use the result of
this computation to show
that
also that you would be able to also
efficiently solve
the the bfs problem
so there is some
relatively simple reduction that happens
there which i'm not going to go into
details
but in our case the problem is slightly
more difficult
because what we what we only need to do
is to see if two bfs trees intersect
right so in their case they were
computing entire bfs3 so there was
enough information to uh to use to use
it to solve the the original k
uh k pointer changing problems
and and in this case we're only gonna
find out one bit do those things
intersect or not it does that does not
seem to be enough to for instance infer
the the full bfs three
four bfs threes from those two vertices
right like in tv it seems that that's
the only thing that the algorithm can do
but but it's not clear why that would be
the case
so let me now introduce as uh as uh um
the following problem which is gonna be
crucial in our analysis
uh so uh so instead of having one
pointer chasing one pointer changing
instance we're gonna have two pointer
chasing instances and so we're gonna
have two sets of players
uh the first is gonna have one instance
the other one is gonna have uh the other
instance and now the question we are
interested in is are the results of
those two pointer chasing
instances the same or not
and
there is like also some small technical
complication in order to make the proof
work is that if one of the functions
uh maps too many too many elements to
the same element
uh then uh we are also supposed to say
yes but but it's not really important
like this because our all our
distributions are going to be uniform
this is going to be very unlikely to
happen
so there are three steps in our proof
so first of all just just just to uh
remind those who are not familiar with
information complexity information
complexity is basically how much the
protocol has to reveal about the inputs
of the players
and there is the distinct distinction
between internal and external
information complexity
but it's not uh it's not important here
because all our distributions are
uniform in which case those those
definitions are the same
so so in the so in the first step of our
proof we showed that the information
complexity of this problem that i just
showed you those two checking whether
the the output of two instances of
uh
of pointer changing is the same
uh the information complexity of this
problem if you want to solve it with
very high probability i have to make
this probability of error
very small like say one over n square
because the probability of the answer is
first of all very no very very low for
uniform distributions so i showed that
for the uniform distribution that this
requires essentially a linear amount of
information exchange this problem right
in the second step
we show
that
if you take multiple instances of this
problem and you try to compute
the disjunction right the basic compute
if if at least one of the instances
gives you the answer yes you want to say
yes
that computing
that solving
k instances
of this problem for some
k which is which is bounded away from
from n
requires essentially k times more
information exchange
as the information complexity grows
grows by a factor of k and
since this this much information is is
being exchanged this also implies the
communication complexity
has to be large as well
not necessarily the same the same thing
finally in the third step i'm going to
show that if the communication com that
the communication complexity of of this
these main problems we're interested in
checking whether two bfs threes
intersect has to be at least the
communication complexity
of uh of checking k instances of uh
uh of uh
of uh
of
this basic building block right whether
there's there's at least one
intersection in
in in this set of uh instances
okay so now i'm gonna quickly uh
go over over those three steps starting
from the last one
so what would you do in the last one
right so we want to show that the
communication complexity of the
of this bfs3 intersection has to be at
least the communication complexity
of of of the disjunction of
of a small number of basic building
blocks
and
so so the way to do it is to show a
protocol for the disjunction that uses
the proto protocol for the bfs
intersection so what can you do so
like the simplest thing you could do is
to just to stack the instances of the
basic building block on top of each
other right
uh so one one one one thing for sure is
if one of the instances was giving you
the answer yes then the resulting bfs
trees are gonna intersect
but the problem now is that even though
the answer might have been no for the
disjunction of those basic building
blocks that suddenly now
some uh
some paths that you get from some
combination of of two different uh
instances my might end up in the same
place as well right
so what do you do
well so so the solution is to randomly
relabel
uh in each instance randomly relabel the
the
the elements at each layer
and unless uh
and unless there is there is there is a
pair there is there is an element
that is a result of mapping of multiple
many other elements then then it's easy
to show that this is this is going to
behave very nicely
right and
and this finishes the proof of step
three
so step two
uh so in step two uh
it's easy it's as well known that the
information because of the entire
protocol is the information cost
of uh for each instance like if you have
a disjunction or conjunction whatever of
different problems it's uh it's
basically the sum of how much gets
revealed for for each instance
for of each sub problem
so so now uh showing this kind of lower
bound would be easy
if if we were required to solve each of
the problems right but the problem is we
only
care about the disjunction of of the
results from from from all these
problems right so so what can we do so
so the easy observation is that because
of how we defined our problem
is
for for a random uh set of uh functions
uh
uh if we fix uh if if you look at the
other instances we pick one instance and
we look at the other instances the
probability of any instances of being
yes is very small
so if we uh so so if we look at all the
other instances then with
probability roughly
1 minus
one k k over n square the probability of
the other instances are all gonna be
false right so we can we can fix the
other instances to some so we just fix
the other instances to something that
gives the answer false and under this
this assumption we have to really solve
this one specific problem right
and
and uh
and it's easy to show
that because the property of these other
instances being false that the
information complexity doesn't doesn't
change right so we are only looking at
some sub distribution we restrict
ourselves to some subset of of of
functions and we show that the
information so then the information
complexity is the information complexity
for a single instance
so the problem is now that the
information complexity could slightly
decrease but because this set has
extremely small probability you can show
that
the information complexity cannot
decrease by too much
for for how much gets revealed about
this specific instance
okay so so the last step is the step
number one in which we show that the
information complexity
of a single basic block has to be at
this omega n
right and so so uh so what is known
about this kind of problem right so so
we know that the communication
complexity for pointer changing is is
omega n for the uniform distribution
so so what are the obstacles well so
first of all we need a proof for uh for
information complexity and then we care
about the quality of two instances of
pointer chasing not just one
so
so let's see so uh so one thing we could
try to use is is is the paper of of jane
radhakrishner and sam
so so they showed that if there is there
is a protocol that reveals uh uh that
reveals uh information complexity
uh say ic
then
and errors represent most epsilon then
there is a protocol
which
uses total communication which is
roughly the information complexity
divided by delta square and errors with
priority epsilon plus delta square right
epsilon plus delta so delta is like this
additional
error we get on top of
the previous protocol in this new
protocol right so basically what it says
if the information is small the
communication has to be small as well
with a constant number of rounds
but it's not good enough for us because
our delta is extremely small right we
have to we have to make sure the problem
gets solved
with a very high probability because the
probability of of the answer being yes
is small right so so we need delta to be
less than one over n so this entity
would give a protocol that uses
extremely
large amount of uh
that could they would be allowed to use
extremely large amount of communication
so that would be not good enough for us
uh so instead of that we have to
introduce a slightly
slightly uh
modified framework
so so we use their techniques to to show
that if there is a protocol that uses a
little information complexity then there
is also a protocol
that is
that is deterministic as with at most
twice the probability and can send
messages
with
very long arbitrary long messages
with uh with probability which is uh
which is uh which is uh like only
polynomial only constant
right so so uh so we're gonna call this
kind of protocol a typically concise
protocol
uh so one interesting thing is the
probability of a long message because
it's gonna
for constant p is only gonna be constant
it's going to be much larger than the
probability of answer yes right so
vertically think things could go wrong
because the the protocol could uh
uh
could always send long messages when the
answer is yes right and this would like
exclude the case we're actually
interested in but the thing is the
protocol won't know
uh intuitively the protocol won't know
when when this happens so it's gonna
send long messages with high constant
probability but it's not gonna kill all
the instances where the answer is yes
so
so how do we proceed so we modify
nissan with gerson's
nissan vigors on proof for uh for uh
pointer chasing
so the original agreement was that
basically we'll get the protocol three
we make uh in simul we simulate in
parallel an algorithm that makes uh
makes like the straightforward step
whenever it can
and we show that uh the
if x is the current current place where
we are in the protocol we showed that
the entropy of the next element which in
the end we want to compute is going to
be very high for most vertices
if the communication is is low so this
basically means that we wouldn't we
wouldn't
know at the end where we really are so
the probability of the problem being
correct is small
so in our case we're gonna simulate uh
we're gonna assume we're gonna do this
for for for both instances of the
pointer chasing right so we have two
values we showed that at any particular
point
like compared to this trigger protocol
which which won't be able to finish uh
to finish to solve the problem in a
specified number of rounds
that for this particular protocol that
the the the entropy of the next element
is going to be very high as well
so what does this mean so
uh so we know that the that in most
leaves of the broccoli protocol
the the probability
of entropy is is very high given given
the transcript of the protocol
so so the problem now is that with with
uh with uh
for for large number of elements
for large number of elements the
probability of receiving this specific
answer
is going to be at least omega 1 over n
so this means that because this this
protocol now is deterministic
and the pointer changing instances are
held by by different set by this joint
sets of players
this means that what we get the prob the
distribution of of solutions from both
pointer chasing instances at any leaf in
the protocol 3
it's it's going to be a product
distribution of what we get from one
pointer chasing instance and from the
other
so if we know that
that for
most elements
we are likely to end up in both pointer
chasing instances there with probability
at least one over n this means that
with with
with probability of this one over n
we're likely to collide the answer is
likely to be s
and it's easy to show that the answer
has to be also known with high
probability
so so because of that these protocols if
they don't use enough communication much
less than n they have to they have to
air with with high probability
so to that that
that's the end of the sketch of the
proof and the last slide
so so so this is the main result we show
uh we show super linear lower bounds for
for a number of uh
of basic graph problems and there are
some some open questions so so first of
all is there a way to make our proof
simpler because it seems that uh given
this previous research there should be
an easy reduction but this is what we
spend a lot of time uh looking into and
eventually have to come up with a more
more intricate uh
more intricate proof then the second
question is is there a way to improve
the lower bound because at this point we
get like the step three it loses a
factor of two it seems
because we end up uh
because the whole idea in this random
scrambling of of of instances is
that
we we have to make sure that the set
sizes are at most root n otherwise by
the birthday paradox we would be very
likely to always get yes as the answer
so so because of that it seems we lose a
factor of two
and
there's of course the question if there
are better better better lower bounds
right because because it seems like no
one really knows how to solve it
uh in a small number of passes with less
than n square space without storing
essentially the entire graph
and it's also a very interesting
question
also a very changing one whether there
is a way to prove something for for
approximate matching not just for the
exact
thank you
questions
it's time